FIRST HEARING FOR THE SENATE
HUMAN SERVICES COMMITTEE OF
THIS YEAR- THE MEETING WILL
COME TORRENT IT LOOKS LIKE WE
HAVE. ENOUGH PEOPLE TO
ESTABLISH A QUORUM SO WE'LL GO
AHEAD AND DO THAT. SECRETARY
PLEASE. TIED UP HERE RICARDO
HERE BELL BELL HERE JACKSON
JACKSON HERE PAN PAN HERE
WIENER. FOR IF WE HAVE FOUR
PEOPLE HERE AND WE- SO TODAY WE
WILL BE LISTENING TO TWO BILLS
ARE THAT ARE ON THE AGENDA IT
WILL BE A SHORT HEARING AND IT
LOOKS LIKE WE HAVE AN AUTHOR
HERE READY TO PRESENT SO.
PLEASE FEEL FREE TO COME UP AND.
GOOD AFTERNOON THANK YOU A MAN
CHAIR. SB THIRTY THREE DEALS
WITH THE FACT THAT. THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT IS NOW GOING TO
ALLOW FOR RECIPIENTS OF OUR EBT
SYSTEM MARK HELFRICH SYSTEM TO
BE ABLE TO USE THEIR BENEFITS
FOR ORDERING FOOD OR ONLINE.
AND AS WE KNOW IN OUR NORMAL
STORE IF YOU'RE THERE YOU CAN
SEE THE FOOD YOU KNOW THAT IT'S
YEAH YOU KNOW THERE'S NOT CAN A
ROTTEN OR WHATEVER. AND WHAT
THIS BILL IS TRYING TO DO IS
CREATE SOME CONSUMER
PROTECTIONS FOR ART EBT
RECIPIENTS SO THAT WHEN THEY
ORDER FOOD ONLINE THEY ARE
PROTECTED AND IT A PROVIDE IT
ALLOWS FOR SAFE AN ETHICAL
STANDARDS FOR ONLINE
PURCHASING. AND IT ESTABLISHES
A WORKING GROUP COMPOSED MAJOR
STAKE HOLDERS INCLUDING THE
DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL SERVICES
TO MAKE SURE THAT WE HAVE
CONSUMER PROTECTIONS IN PLACE
WHEN A CALPERS RECIPIENT USES
THEIR CALPERS BENEFITS TO ORDER
ONLINE FOOD. AND WITH THAT I
LET MY WITNESSES TO PRESENT.
KEVIN AS THE COALITION
CALIFORNIA WHAT FOR ITS
ORGANIZATION FOR THE WHAT
HAPPENED TO YOU- WITH- WITH
SUPPORTERS BUILT- THIS BILL
WILL AFFECT TWO POINT TWO
MILLION HOUSEHOLDS IN
CALIFORNIA. THE AVERAGE
BENEFITS THE PAY OF A PERSON
GETS A HUNDRED TWENTY SIX
DOLLARS AND WITH GOING ONLINE
WE WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
COULD DEVELOP PROCESSES
COLLABORATIVELY WITH THE
DEPARTMENT. AND OF STAKEHOLDERS
TO MAKE SURE THAT THE PROCESSES
THANKS THE BENEFITS WITH
SPECIALLY IN CLIENTS LIVING IN
RURAL REYES WHO DO WHO ARE NOT
ABLE TO GO DOWN TO THE STORE
AND GET GOOD STUFF THIS WITH A
COULD GIVE. THE THIRD FOOD AND
THREE THE CHILDREN DISCIPLINE
WILL DRIVE VOTE THANK YOU. ARE
THERE ANY MEMBERS OF PUBLIC
THAT WISH TO US STATE THEIR
PUBLIC SUPPORT. YES KATHY MUST
FOR CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
FOOD BANKS IN SUPPORT. DO WE
HAVE ANY ADDITIONAL. PEOPLE IN
SUPPORT ANYONE OPPOSED. OKAY.
ANY COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS SENATOR PAN
THANK YOU- IS THERE SKINNER FOR
BRINGING THIS BILL FORWARD
CERTAINLY WE DO WANT TO TRY TO
SALVAGE THE STANDARDS BEFORE
ANY I KNOW THAT THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT RIGHT NOT QUITE
THERE YET- EVEN THOUGH- THE
WINDING AND BEETHOVEN AND
ALICE'S WAS THE MENTION THAT-
PERHAPS THE OFFICE OF SYSTEMS
INTEGRATION THE FARM HEALTH AND
HUMAN SERVICES SHOULD ALSO BE
PART OF THE STAKEHOLDER GROUPS
SINCE THEY ARE THE PRIDE THE
IMPLEMENTERS AS THE IT
DEPARTMENT FOR THE JET AGE SO
IS THAT YOUR AND DO YOU PLAN TO
DO THAT- IT'S NOT CLEAR FIGHT
BECAUSE THAT WAS A COMMENT IN
THE- IN THE ANALYSIS RIGHT. NOW
IT'S TIME IT IS DSS THAT WOULD-
FIGURE OUT WHO THE STATE CALLED
WERE WE CERTAINLY CAN RECOMMEND
TO THEM AND OF COURSE PART OF
OUR ISSUE IS NOT SO MUCH. AND I
KNOW THAT THIS ISN'T WHERE
YOU'RE GOING BUT NOT SO MUCH-
IMPROVING THE RECIPIENTS YOU
KNOW ONLINE CAPABILITIES BUT
MORE THAT. AND AGAIN WERE YOU
KNOW WE DON'T WANT TO ASSUME AT
ALL THAT ANY BUSINESS THAT
YOU'RE YOU YOU KNOW ORDERING
ONLINE IS IN ANY WAY- TRYING TO
TAKE ADVANTAGE OF YOU BUT LET'S
SAY THEY SEND YOU. NOT WHEN
YOUR. OR WHAT'S OUT OF DATE OR
WHATEVER NOW YOU'VE GIVEN OF
YOU'VE GIVEN THEM EBT BENEFIT
NOT AT. ARE YOU GOING TO BE
ABLE TO RECOVER THAT ARE YOU
GONNA BE ABLE TO- YOU KNOW THAT
IT'S THAT SORT OF THING THAT WE
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT THE EBT
RECIPIENT HAS THE SAME TYPE OF
CONSUMER PROTECTIONS THAT YOU
AND I HAVE. YEAH. SHE DID
ANSWER I KNOW YOU'LL BE WORKING
ON THIS BILL AND I WOULD BE
HAPPY TO DO THAT AT THIS TIME.
OKAY OKAY. WELL. WHEN THE STUDY
THIS IF THEY COULD STUDY THINGS
LIKE A LOT OF PEOPLE GET THEIR
DIET DIET FOOD. IN DELIVER TO
THROUGH THIS MEANS I DON'T KNOW
IF THIS IS APPLICABLE TO THAT
AND THEN. THERE'S A LOT OF
PEOPLE THAT HAVE. AS YOU KNOW
PROBABLY THERE A LOT OF PEOPLE
THAT. LIKE THE HOME DELIVERY
THE FOOD YOU KNOW LIKE. NEWS OF
WILK YEAH YEAH BUT OTHERS I
RESTAURANTS RIGHT BUT BUT
PROFIT MAKING COMPANY YES DO IT
YOU KNOW YES THEY DID. DELIVER
FRESH GROCERIES. THAT KIND OF
STUFF TO PEOPLE'S HOUSES YEAH I
ALWAYS KIND OF WONDER. HOW MUCH
IS REALLY OF THE REGULAR CHARGE
HOW MUCH IS THERE SOME KIND OF
HIDDEN BUILT IN RIGHT SERVICE
CHARGE OR WHATEVER YOU KNOW.
AND WHAT'S THE RULE ON EASY TO
USE FOR LIKE SERVICE CHARGES
FOR DELIVERIES IS THERE. IS
THERE A STANDARD YES HELLO.
EXACTLY KNOW THAT KIND OF THING
AND FOR THE FOR THE- I KNOW THE
ONES THAT ARE DELIVERED FOR THE.
DIET THE CHARGE THE CHARGE
SERVICE FEES SOMETIMES YOU KNOW
FOR PEOPLE. AND IS SPECIALLY IF
THEY START BEING REAL SPECIFIC
ABOUT THEIR DIET YOU GENERALLY
WANT LIKE. SO THEY WANT VEGAN
OR YOU KNOW. KOSHER WHATEVER
BUT ALSO DIET IN A LIKE BECAUSE
THOSE ARE THE KINDS OF THINGS
WE WOULD ANTICIPATE THAT DSS
WOULD- THINK ABOUT IS LIKE ALL
RIGHT IS THE EBT CARD OR THE
EBT BENEFIT THAT WHICH IS GOING
TO PAY FOR THE DELIVERY OR NOT
IF THERE'S A DELIVERY CHARGE.
AND RIGHT AND ALSO WE'VE NOW
ALLOWED FOR. A LIMITED AMOUNT
OF VB T. FOR A RESTAURANT MEAL
SO WITH THAT COVER SAY THE DOOR
DASH DELIVERY THAT THOSE ARE
THE KINDS OF THINGS OKAY. YEAH.
AND CENTER JACK'S PLACE. OF
QUESTIONS I NOTED THAT THIS
BILL- HEADED PRIOR ITERATION IS
SB SIX SEVENTY FIVE WHAT HI
THIS IS BILL THEIR FEAR FROM
RIGHT SO IN SIX SEVENTY FIVE WE
WERE ALREADY TRYING TO BE.
DESCRIPTIVE BUT PREDICT TO WHAT
TYPE OF CONSUMER PROTECTIONS
THE- BENEFICIARY SHOULD HAVE A
OF IN RELATIONSHIP TO THE
VENDOR WHO MIGHT BE. PROVIDING
THEM EITHER THE MEAL FOR THE
FOOD USING THE EBT BENEFITS
RIGHT SO WE WERE BEING SPECIFIC
AND THAT WAS IN IN JUST MOVING
IT THROUGH THE PROCESS NUMBER
ONE WE ALWAYS RUN INTO A COST
PROBLEM WHEN WE'RE BEING THAT
SPECIFIC AND NUMBER TWO IT WAS
SETTING OF THE AGENCY NOT
REALLY. WHILE WHILE I WILL SAY
I THINK THAT MUCH OF WHAT WE
IDENTIFIED IS PROBABLY SPOT ON
IT IS BETTER TO HAVE THE
STAKEHOLDERS DEVELOP THAT
BECAUSE THEY'RE GOING TO NO
THEN THE DESIGN IT SO THAT IT'S
MOST EASILY IMPLEMENTABLE AND
SO THAT'S WHY WE WENT BACK. WE.
IN EFFECT REVAMPED AND DECIDED
ALL RIGHT INSTEAD WE WILL
DIRECT THE DEPARTMENT TO SET UP
A STAKEHOLDER PROCESS TO COME
UP WITH THOSE THINGS. AND THE
OTHER QUESTION IS- THIS SEEMS
LIKE AN IDEAL PROGRAM FOR
SENIORS AND PEOPLE WHO
OTHERWISE MORE HOUSEBOUND. THAN
OTHERS IS THERE GOING TO BE ANY
SUGGESTION TO. THAT FOCUS ON
THIS NOT NECESSARILY PRIMARILY
BUT AT LEAST AS PART OF THE
WHOLE DISCUSSION HOW WE'RE
GONNA MAKE SURE THAT THAT. IN
YOU KNOW PEOPLE WHO MAY NOT
ACTUALLY HAVE ACCESS TO ON LINE
OPPORTUNITIES. OR MAY BUT
CANNOT CANNOT LEAVE THEIR HOMES
AND SO FORTH OF MIGHT BE ABLE
TO ENSURE ACCESS TO THIS KIND
OF A PROGRAM NO IT'S
INTERESTING CONCEPT IS
CERTAINLY MORE AND MORE ARE
SENIORS ARE EVEY T. RECIPIENTS.
YEAH I CHOSE THE ABSCESS YOU
MOVE THE BILL FORWARD YOU COULD
MAKE SOME REFERENCE TO HAS YES
KNOWLEDGE THAT ADDITIONAL NEED
THANK YOU GOOD. THANK YOU
SENATOR SKINNER WOULD LIKE TO
CLOSE- WITH THAT BY S. ZERO
VOTE. SO WE HAVE A MOTION- BY
SENATOR PAN AND THAT MOTION IS
TO PASS THE SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. THE MEASURES SB
THIRTY THREE SENATOR SKINNER.
THE MOTION IS TO PASSED
APPROPRIATIONS OUR DAUGHTER. HI
RICARDO I BELL. BELL I JACKSON.
JACKSON AYE PAN PAN AYE WIENER.
FORCE OF FOR. OKAY TO VOTE AT
WE CURRENTLY HAVE FOUR VOTES
AND WE WILL HOLD. WITH ON CALL.
THANK YOU. IF UP NEXT IS ITEM
NUMBER TWO SB FIVE NINE SIX
SENATOR STERN WOULD YOU. LIKE
TO COME UP AND PRESENT. FEEL
FREE TO START WHENEVER YOU OKAY
THANK YOU ENSURING GOOD
AFTERNOON MEMBERS. FIRST I JUST
WANT TO START OFF BANKING
COMMITTEE FOR THEIR VERY
THOROUGH AND USEFUL ANALYSIS-
AND HAPPY TO ACCEPT THE
AMENDMENTS PROPOSED- THE BILL
EMANATES FROM THE CRISES WE'VE
BEEN GOING THROUGH. WHO REALLY
POINTEDLY- THIS FALL BUT BEEN
REALLY THROUGHOUT THE LAST YEAR
YEAR AND A HALF AS UTILITY
STARTED USING PUBLIC SAFETY
POWER SHUT OFF IS ONE WAY THAT
THEY ARE GOING TO CHOOSE TO
MITIGATE FIRE RISK IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA AND- WITH ALL
CRIME EMERGENCIES WE KNOW THAT
THE- THE- MOST LOW INCOME MOST
VULNERABLE PEOPLE GET HIT FIRST
AND SO IN THIS CASE WE FOUND A
NEW. VICTIM OF THIS CRISIS AND
THAT- LOT IHS RECIPIENTS AROUND
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA WERE
ALSO ALIGNING WITH THOSE IN
THEIR POWER SHUT OFF AND THESE
ARE PEOPLE WHO MIGHT NOT EVEN
BE AWARE THAT THERE ARE UTILITY
PROGRAMS OUT THERE TO SIGN UP
FOR WHAT THEY CALL MEDICAL
BASELINE RATE- THAT INSURE
CERTAIN PROTECTIONS. CONTINUITY
OF CARE WITH YOUR ELECTRICITY
SAY FOR KEEPING YOUR MEDICINE
REFRIGERATED YOUR RESPIRATOR
ON- AND SO WITH THIS BILL IT'S
PRETTY SIMPLE I DON'T THINK
GOING TO SOLVE THE ENTIRE
PROBLEM. BUT AT AT THE VERY
LEAST- START TO UTILIZE THE HSS
NETWORK TO LET THE CUSTOMERS
KNOW WHAT WHAT RESOURCES THEY
HAVE AVAILABLE ON THE UTILITY
SIDE- AND I THINK THE LAST
PIECE I WOULD JUST A HEARING.
THE WORKERS WHO DO THIS WORK
THE IHS AS WORKERS OUR FRIENDS
TO DO W. ME. UP THOSE FOLKS A
BEARD. GOING THROUGH THE P. S.
P. S. CYCLE LAST TIME AND
STRETCHED AND WORKED OVERTIME
AND SORT OF WENT ABOVE AND
BEYOND. SO PLEASE KEEP IN MIND
AS WE GO FORWARD YOU KNOW.
NEED TO HELP MINISTER
EFFECTIVELY OUR SERVICES SO IF
YOU THINK ABOUT WHO CAN GET A
POWER PACKER GENERATOR OUT TO
YOUR GRANDMOTHER OR SOMEONE
ELSE WAS HOME. ON A HOME
SUPPORT SERVICES. WE'RE
STARTING A PUZZLE ON WHETHER.
THE HEALTH SIDE IS AT A BETTER
ACCESS POINT AND SAY. RUNNING
SOME OTHER PC PROGRAM BUT FOR
RIGHT NOW THE BILL'S PRETTY
LIMITED IN SCOPE- AND IT'S JUST
SAYING COUNTIES- NEED TO FIND
SOME WAY TO INFORM MY TO ASSIST
CUSTOMERS THAT THEY'RE ELIGIBLE
FOR THIS MEDICAL BASELINE.
PROGRAM SORRY FOR THE LONG
WINDED INTRODUCTION- WE DO HAVE
WITH US TODAY BEVERLY YOU WITH
A U. D. W. I DON'T KNOW IF
CHRIS CHILDS HERE'S DISABILITY
RIGHTS CALIFORNIA BUT
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AYE VOTE
AND- WELCOME ANY OTHER.
QUESTIONS. AFTER NAY MADAM
CHAIR MEMBERS THE REALLY YOU ON
BEHALF OF U. D. W. ASKED ME
LOCAL THREE NINE THIRTY. WE
REPRESENT A HUNDRED FIFTEEN
THOUSAND HOME CARE PROVIDERS TO
TAKE CARE OF LOW INCOME SENIORS
AND PEOPLE WITH DISABILITIES.
AND THEY ARE THE MOST LIKELY TO
BE INJURED OR DIE IN THE EVENT
OF A POWER SHUT OFF FOR
WILDFIRE. WELL THE STATE
CONTINUES TO EXPLORE LONG TERM
SOLUTIONS IT IS CRITICAL THEIR
PROVIDERS AND CLIENTS KNOW.
ABOUT THE MEDICAL BASELINE
PROGRAMS AND THIS IS ESPECIALLY
IMPORTANT FOR CLIENTS WHO RELY
ON LIFE SUPPORT EQUIPMENT HAVE
LIFE THREATENING ILLNESSES. OR
COMPROMISED IMMUNE SYSTEMS. THE
MEDICAL BASS FINALIST CAN SAVE
LIVES AS PART OUR- I DON'T.
CUSTOMERS A NEED I A VANCE
NOTIFICATION. LIKE TO THANK THE
AUTHOR AND STAFF FOR BRING THIS
BILL FORWARD SB SIX TO PROTECT
OUR MEMBERS AND CLIENTS DURING
THESE LIFE THREATENING. EVENTS
SO THEY CAN BETTER PLAN FOR
EMERGENCIES. DR VOTE THANK YOU.
THE CHECKER CHILD DISABILITY
RIGHTS CALIFORNIA- AS WE
CERTAINLY FOUND OVER THE COURSE
OF THIS LAST FALL THE- POWER
SHUT OFFS- ENDED UP HAVING JUST
THE THREAT TO THESE POWER SHOPS
HAVING DRAMATIC EFFECTS ON
PERSONS WITH DISABILITIES- BOTH
THE AREAS AND MUCH MORE-
BROADLY- WE APPRECIATE CENTER
STERN'S EFFORT ON ON THIS BILL
IMPORTANTLY BE THERE BECOMES
THIS VIEW THAT WE'VE GOT THE
MEDICAL BASELINE PROGRAM AND
THAT IS A- SUFFICIENT- PROGRAM
TO PROVIDE NOTICE IT FALLS WELL
SHORT OF THE- RELATIONS THAT WE
KNOW WE NEED. TO BUT IS TO IN
THE BAND. VERY SHORT NOTICE OF
POWER UPS. EFFORT THAT WE CAN
TAKE REACH OTHER POPULATIONS
THAT WE KNOW BOTH TO GET THEM
WITH THE DIRECT NOTICE BUT TO
GET THEM ALL ON TO- THE MEDICAL
BASS LINE TO TAKE ADVANTAGE OF
THE NOTIFICATIONS THERE- ARE
EXTREMELY IMPORTANT. AND DOES
SO WE CERTAINLY APPRECIATE
THIS- THIS EFFORT AND WE LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH SENATOR
STERN AS WELL. I KNOW WHAT
OTHER- NOTIFICATIONS THROUGHOUT
THE BENEFIT PROGRAMS-
THROUGHOUT THE STATE TO ENSURE
THAT THE POPULATIONS ARE GOING
TO GET- THE NOTIFICATION THIS
IS ONLY ONE SMALL PIECE OF A
YOU ARE BETTER THAN I. AM A
MUCH BROADER PROBLEM WITH THE
IMPACTING. OF THE GLOBAL
POPULATIONS- SO WE APPRECIATE
YOUR AYE VOTE THANK YOU. DO WE
HAVE ANY MEMBERS OF PUBLIC AND
SUPPORT PLEASE COME UP STATE
YOUR NAME AND ORGANIZATION.
JOHN KENNEDY WITH WORLD COUNTY
REPRESENTATIVES OF CALIFORNIA
IN STRONG SUPPORT WE APPRECIATE
THE AUTHOR BRINGING THIS BILL
FORWARD- WE'RE VERY CONCERNED
ABOUT MEDICALLY SENSITIVE
POPULATIONS AND- AND THE IMPACT
OF PS PS OF AND ON THOSE
POPULATIONS. IN UNDER GRAD
PROGRAM IN THIS REALLY HELPS US
GET THE NOTIFICATION AND
NEGATION OF IMPACT TO THOSE ASM
POPULATION SO THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. LET ME SAY THIS ON BEHALF
OF KAPPA FOR HSS AND AT THE A
YOU CALIFORNIA AND SUPPORT. DO
WE HAVE ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL. THREE
NINE OKAY ADDITIONALLY ARE
THERE ARE SOME QUESTIONS ABOUT
HOW THE BILL IMPRINT- WOULD BE
IMPLEMENTED. AND SO SHOULD THE
BILL MOVE FORWARD. YOU DON'T.
JUST ASK IN DARK THE AUTHOR
MIGHT CONSIDER THE FOLLOWING
WHAT DOES INFORMING IN THE
CONTEXT OF THE BILL- WELL THE
COUNTIES BE RESPONSIBLE FOR
PRIVATE PROVIDING FOR
INFORMATION ABOUT THE PROGRAM.
OF ALL THE TAKE UP WILL BE HAVE
TO MAKE A REFERRAL. OUT WILL
VERBAL NOTICE SUFFICE A WHAT
ENTITIES WILL BE REQUIRED TO
DEVELOP INFORMATION REGARDING
MEDICAL BASELINE. WILL IT BE
THE COUNTY IS THE UTILITIES OR
SOME OTHER ENTITY- IS INITIAL
APPLICATION THE APPROPRIATE
TIME TO NOTIFY INDIVIDUALS. OF
MEDICAL BASS LINE OR WOULD IT
BE MORE APPROPRIATE TO NOTIFY
RECIPIENTS AT THE TIME OF
APPLICATION AND REASSESSMENT.
ODD THE OTHER BY REACHING THE
FULL POPULATION OF AYE HSS
RECIPIENTS. I WITH THE ANALYSIS
WAS SPOT ON IN IN SORT OF
IDENTIFYING HOW TO MAKE THE
MECHANICS WORK AND WE'RE VERY
OPENED ITS STAYING CLOSE
WORKING CLOSELY WITH THIS
COMMITTEE AND LET YOU GUYS.
HELP US SHAPE. OF A EFFICIENT.
SORT INTERVENTION PROCESS WHERE
WE'RE TAKING ADVANTAGE OF
EXISTING DOLLARS IN EXISTING
PROGRAMS RIGHT WHAT IF
UTILITIES ALREADY HAVE OUT
THERE AND HOW NOT TO SORT OF
OVER BURDENS SAY THE COUNTIES
OR ANYONE ENTITY SO A VERY OPEN
TO. THINKING THROUGH MECHANICS
AND- MAKING SURE THE PROCESS OF
INFORMING. IS GOING TO BE
TAILORED IN A WAY THAT REALLY
HELPS THIS POPULATION I MEAN
RIGHT NOW WE'VE GOT. OVER I
THINK IT'S OVER FIVE AND FORTY
THOUSAND I JUSTICE CLIENTS IN
THE CITY CALIFORNIA AND- TOTAL
THERE'S ONLY THREE TO FORTY
THOUSAND PEOPLE SIGNED UP FOR
MEDICAL BASELINE STATEWIDE. SO
WE ACTUALLY THINK THE
POPULATION OF OLDER PEOPLE IS
BROADER THAN I HSS EVEN I MEAN
IF YOU LOOK AT THE WHOLE AXIS
OF FUNCTIONAL NEEDS COMMUNITY
LIKE THAT'S PROBABLY A BIGGER
NUMBER WE WANT TO START HERE
AND AT LEAST GET THE
CONVERSATION GOING BUT- MADAM
CHAIR I. I THINK- YOUR
EXPERTISE IN THIS HEARING
COMMITTEE DIGGING IN HELPING US
FLETCHER THAT WOULD BE. VERY
WELCOME SO- YEAH THANK YOU YEAH
THANK YOU ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM COMMITTEE PROCESS
WILL START CENTER JACKSON AND
THEN CENTER PAN YEAH THE THANK
YOU. AND THANK YOU FOR THOSE
QUESTIONS I THINK IT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT- OBVIOUSLY THIS BILL.
NEEDS A LOT. OF WORK IT'S SORT
OF GOTTEN AMENDED APPROACHES.
AN OBVIOUS PROBLEM BUT WE- OF
AS AS WE TRY TO DEAL WITH- A
EXPANDING THIS AS YOU JUST
MENTIONED TO ACCESS AND THE
ACCESS OF. FUNCTIONAL NEEDS
COMMUNITY- A I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT THAT. WE NOT CREATE
SO MANY LAYERS OF. IRAQ CHRISSY
THAT IS SOME LAYERS INCLUDES
SOME GROUP IN SOME INCLUDE
ANOTHER AND WE'VE GOT
LEGISLATION I KNOW THAT YOU AND
I ARE BOTH DOING THE TO MAKE
SURE ON EMERGENCY ALERTS THESE
PEOPLE ARE. EARLY IN THE IN THE
QUEUE SO THAT THINGS CAN BE
DONE TO HELP THEM EXPEDITE
THEIR THE ASSISTANCE FOR THEM I
JUST CAUTION AND JUST URGE
THAT. AS THIS BILL EVOLVES THAT
WE TAKE INTO ACCOUNT THAT YOU
DON'T WANT IT'S TO BE SO.
SPECIFIC DAD IT INCLUDES-
DOESN'T INCLUDE SO THAT IF IT
IS IN FACT THE COUNTIES THAT WE
REQUIRED TO DO THIS VERSES THE
UTILITIES OR WHOEVER IT IS THAT
ALSO. GOING TO TAKE
RESPONSIBILITY FOR AN EFFECTIVE
PROGRAM ISN'T JUST ONE OF
SEVERAL SO THAT WHEN WE- WHEN
WE DO OUR- SORT OF THE- MAP OUT
THE- THE CHANGE
RESPONSIBILITIES IT LOOKS LIKE
A- YOU KNOW AN ALGORITHM
ITSELF. IT'S GOT TO BE I WOULD
SUGGEST PART OF A BROADER BUT
MORE COMPREHENSIVE- PROGRAM TO
ADDRESSING THE NEEDS OF THESE
FOLKS WHETHER IT BE A PSP A
SITUATION OR AN EMERGENCY
SITUATION OR GAINING ACCESS TO
THIS- REDUCE ELECTRICITY RATES
THESE ARE. THESE ARE FOLKS AND
WITHIN THAT. THAT STE THAT
GROUP THE SUBSETS. OF
INDIVIDUALS WE SHOULD BE
ADDRESSING ALL OF THESE ISSUES-
COLLECTIVELY RATHER THAN SAYING
WELL WE'VE GOT THIS GROUP OVER
HERE AND THEN COUNTY WILL HAVE
TO DO THIS FOR THIS GROUP. HERE
SO THAT WE END UP WITH SUCH A
QUAGMIRE. WHICH IS TO AND DON'T
KNOW WHAT THE RESPONSIBILITIES
ARE SO I THINK IF WE INCLUDE
THESE ALL AS PART OF A VERY
NECESSARY GROUP OF PEOPLE WITH
FUNCTIONAL NEEDS- I HSS WORK.
OF THE PEOPLE OF RECEIVING THIS
THIS ASSISTANCE IT'S ALL PART
OF A- OF A BIGGER WHOLE THAT WE
SHOULD BE ADDRESSING SO THAT WE
DON'T JUST KEEP CARVING IT UP
AND CONFUSING THE HECK OUT OF
OUR BUREAUCRATS IN OUR COUNTY
PEOPLE AS WELL. AND IF I MAY
THERE'S THIS THING IS TMI RIGHT
THERE'S TOO MUCH INFORMATION
SOMETIMES IF YOU'RE GETTING.
YOU KNOW GETTING UP. SOMETHING
FROM ONE AGENCY IN SOMETHING
ELSE FROM ANOTHER ANY SCENES I
MEAN WE'VE DEALT WITH THE LACK
OF UNIFIED COMMUNICATIONS
AROUND CRISES. SO I THINK
YOU'RE RIGHT THAT THE GOAL OF
THE BILL SHOULD BE. AN
INTEGRATED AND SORT OF
STREAMLINED APPROACH THAT'S.
CALLIE CHURCHES FOR INSTANCE
HAD A HOTLINE THEY WERE THE
ONLY ONES SECRETARY GOLLY
STEPPED UP AND PUT A HOTLINE
TOGETHER SO PEOPLE ACTUALLY
HAVE SOMEONE TO CALL IF THERE
COUNTY TWO ONE ONE DIDN'T WORK
TO TRY TO FIGURE OUT. CAN I GET
A GENERATOR WHERE DO I GO- GOD
BLESS HIM FOR I MEAN <c.cyan>y THEY</c>
GOT THAT STOOD UP QUICKLY. BUT
NOW YOU'VE GOT. THAT PIECE OF
INFORMATION OUT THERE DOES IT
DOES IT JUST DANGLE OFTEN
EITHER DOES ANYONE ACTUALLY
KNOW ABOUT IT WHEN YOU GET THAT
COMMUNICATION TOUCH POINT
ESPECIALLY WITH SOMEONE IN A
VULNERABLE COMMUNITY YOU GOT TO
USE IT EFFICIENTLY. RIGHT YOU
DON'T WANT A FLOW CHART THAT
READS LIKE A ROCKET TO THE MOON
YEAH IT'S GOT TO BE SIMPLE.
THAT'S WHEN TAKEN ABSOLUTELY.
BUT CENTER PAN. I THANK YOU SO
MUCH- AND FIRST BY ONE THANK
YOU CENTER STERN FOR BRINGING
THIS BILL FORWARD CLEARLY IT-
TRYING TO ADDRESS A VERY
IMPORTANT NEED BE SHARING THAT
ENSURING THAT PEOPLE WHO ARE
VULNERABLE HAVE THE INFORMATION
THEY NEED TO HELP. PROTECT
THEMSELVES CERTAINLY THE
POSITION I'VE SEEN SITUATIONS
WHERE- YOU KNOW PEOPLE ARE
DEPENDENT THIS IS LIFESAVING
EQUIPMENT AND IF IT POWER GOES
DOWN THERE'S NO POWER FOR IT I
MEAN THEY CAN DIE AND SO IT'S
IMPORTANT AND I THINK THE I
JUST US PROGRAM GIVEN THE
POPULATION THAT USES AYE HSS IS
ONLY ONE VEHICLE BY WHICH WE
CAN COMMUNICATE TO PEOPLE OVER
MOST MOST LIKELY WHO NEED THESE
TYPES OF SERVICES AND SUPPORTS-
I UP I DO- ALSO SHARE THE
CHAIRS- I THINK OF CONCERNS
RIGHT WORD BUT- DESIRE TO SEE
MORE OF THE DETAILS FILLED IN-
AND- CERTAINLY IS THIS BILL
MOVES FORWARD I DON'T KNOW- AND
SURE WHETHER. SINCE WE DO HAVE
THESE QUESTIONS OBVIOUSLY OF
DEADLINES AND I WANT TO BE SURE
THIS BILL MOVES FORWARD THAT-
WHEN WE HAVE MORE THOSE DETAILS
THAT WE MIGHT BE ABLE TO WHEN
IT COMES BACK TO HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY HERE WHAT THEY ARE.
A SO JUST WANT TO PUT THAT OUT
THERE SO THAT WE CAN UNDERSTAND
HOW THAT FILLS OUT BUT-
CERTAINLY ONE OF THEM'S THE
BILL TODAY NO THE TO WORK ON AS
WITH THE SPONSORSHIPS AND WOULD
BE HAPPY TO MOVE TO THE TIME
THANK YOU DOCTOR PAN AND STRONG
WELCOME YOUR INPUT HERE- WE'RE
TRYING TO GET THINGS MOVING
QUICKLY BECAUSE- RINGO THROUGH.
ANOTHER A TIME. RIGHT IT'S LIKE
WE LEFT ALL THE PC WELL THAT'S
NOT GONNA WORK. BUT HAVING NOT.
LOAD THIS UP TOO MUCH AND IT'S
A SENSITIVE COST FRAMEWORK IN
THAT SPACE TO WRITE SO I'M- I'M
WARY OF ALL THAT AND I AM JUST
THINKING CREATIVELY I MEAN I
KEEP THINKING. IF THE I'LL YOU
ARE GOING TO EXPAND THE MONEY
THAT THEY'RE ALREADY SUPPOSED
TO BE SPENDING TO TELL THEIR
CUSTOMERS ABOUT IT. WHY SHOULD
WE JUST LET THE I JUST AS
WORKERS AND CAL HHS. DO THAT
THEMSELVES IF THEY ALREADY
TALKING TO THOSE SAME PEOPLE SO
THOSE ARE IDEAS OF THINGS
WHERE. YOU'RE NOT GONNA ADD
COST PRESSURE NECESSARILY ALSO
ON TO THESE PROGRAMS BUT MAY
BE- MAKE IT MORE EFFICIENT SO-
I WILL HEED YOUR POINT AND-
YEAH WELCOME WELCOME THE INPUT
GOING FORWARD. I MAY SAY I ALSO
MENTIONED THAT BOTH THE CHAIR
OF THIS COMMITTEE AS WELL AS
MYSELF ALSO SERVE ON THE BUDGET
SUBCOMMITTEE SO GOOD. SO WE CAN
TALK ABOUT MONEY TO. YEAH LET'S
DO IT. GOOD WELL THANK YOU
CENTERS CLOSE AT THIS TIME SURE.
THIS IS A VERY HUMAN ISSUE AND-
YOU KNOW PEOPLE IN THIS STATE
ARE LOOKING FOR ANSWERS RIGHT
NOW FROM THE LEGISLATURE'S I
JUST APPRECIATE THE WILLINGNESS
TO TRY TO GET SOME MORE PRODUCT
GOING HERE QUICKLY AND TRY TO
REACH PEOPLE WHO MIGHT
OTHERWISE BE LEFT BEHIND-
HOPEFULLY IS POWER SHUT OFF
DYNAMIC. LIMITS ITSELF IN THE
COMING MONTHS WE CAN'T AFFORD
TO JUST HOPE SO WITH THAT
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR IT. THANK
YOU. SO WE DO HAVE A MOTION ON
SB FIVE NINE SIX BY SENATOR
PAN. THAT RECOMMENDEDMOTIONS
TO PASS AS AMENDED TO SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS A SEPARATE
CHECKING PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
FOR TITLE I RETIRED A AYE BELL.
BELL I JACKSON JACKSON AYE PAN
PAN HI WINNER. AT HIS WORDS SO
WE HAVE A VOTE OF FOUR ZERO
WORK AT A PLACE THE BILL ON
CALL JUST TO ALLOW OTHER
COMMITTEE MEMBERS TO. GET ABOUT
.
ALL RIGHT WE ARE OPEN NOT.
OPENING THE ROLE FOR SENATE
BILL. THIRTY THREE THIRTY THREE
FIVE CENTER SKINNER. OUR
SECRETARY YOU PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL NOT. SB THIRTY THREE THE
MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS CARE BOATS HI
WIENER. WIENER AYE. THAT'S FIVE
SO THE IS FIVE. ZERO AND THAT
BILL IS OUT. NEXT ONE IS SB
FIVE NINETY SIX SENATORS STERN
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS CHAIR
VOTES I AND WIENER. WIENER HIGH.
FIVE SO THAT- THE BILL HAS A
VOTE OF FIVE ZERO AND THE BILL
IS NOT. NO OF COURSE SO THANK
YOU ALL FOR BEING HERE THAT IN
OUR COMMITTEE HEARING TODAY
THANK YOU